the first thing I will say is that
unfortunately we have generally seen a
retreat in the role of Europe in general
when it comes to the Arab world it's not
just Europe even the United States seems
to have largely retreated when it comes
to the Middle East at large and the Arab
world in particular and this has opened
the space for regional actors to play a
more active role in the Arab world in
particular and here I'm talking about
Turkey Iran as well as of course Arab
actors like Saudi Arabia and Qatar who
all have regional ambitions so the
landscape and the Arab world has been
changing slightly it's no longer a case
of the West in a way influencing things
on the ground if anything people in the
region are a bit critical that they have
not received enough support from the
West and Europe in particular especially
since 2011 when the uprisings in the
region started one thing that is now a
crucial issue is the security angle as
you know several countries in the region
are in conflict Libya as mentioned is
one country that is now undergoing
complete chaos and that is partly
because this enthusiasm on part of
Europe to change the regime in Libya was
not met with a viable security strategy
aimed at stabilizing the country after
the removal of Qaddafi one reason behind
this was lack of adequate understanding
on part of the international community
of the local dynamics in Libya there was
the sonne assumption that these rebels
that had asked for international
intervention would have the capacity to
carry the country towards
democratization but of course this
missed the huge issue of the need for
security sector reform and a security
strategy to secure Libya before any of
the political transition could actually
be viable
so here the role of Europe has been one
of lack of understanding unfortunately
and perhaps being too hasty and
expecting transformation to happen we
shouldn't expect any country really to
have a constitution ready in six months
after having emerged from decades of
autocracy and I'm afraid that the same
formula applies to other places in the
region not just Libya and I think Egypt
also demonstrates another situation in
which we've seen this eternal optimism
being hit with the harsh reality that
again rushing a country to write a
constitution and expecting it to just
become democratic and a very short
period of time is just not realistic and
what we've seen in Egypt in particular
is a case of inattention by Europe to
the importance of good governance when
it comes to not just democratic
transition but in general what I'm
saying here is that the optimism that
happened regarding Egypt after the 2011
uprising was coupled with turning a
blind eye to the transgressions of the
government that took over in Egypt at
that time which was an Islamist
government led by the Muslim Brotherhood
this government tried to in a way
Islamized the system it engaged in
transgressions at the human rights and
freedom of expression levels and yet
everybody was saying but no this was a
democratically elected government so we
should just support it well yes we
should support a democratic
democratically elected government but
you should not do that
without saying to any government that
support should
only happen if these governments abide
by accountability transparency basically
good governance our values then we had a
complete shift in Egypt with the change
of regimes with the current president
Sisi and unfortunately we saw the same
process continue Europe is still turning
a blind eye to the transgressions
happening in Egypt in fact in the UK we
saw a president Sisi being welcomed at
the same time as people being jailed in
Egypt the Muslim Brotherhood being
cracked down on so neither Islamists nor
secularists I don't think we should take
sides when it comes to ideology but what
Europe should have done is stick by its
own values unfortunately we are once
again seeing this formula of thinking
that European values belong in Europe
and perhaps the rest of the world you
know can can kind of abide by other
values and we Ally ourselves with these
other countries on the basis of security
alliances primarily and democracy
suffers in the process so this has been
unfortunately a process that has been
going on since before the Arab uprisings
and it's really unfortunate that Europe
does not seem to have learnt very much
since those days the other issue that is
of crucial importance is that of the
economy Europe is very optimistic about
one country in the region and rightly so
which is Tunisia because despite all the
kind of sad stories that we are seeing
in the region here is one country that
is actually on the path towards
democratization and yet the
democratization process in Tunisia risks
being derailed because of the economy in
the country which is now at only zero
7% growth and expected to have to
recession in the coming year and yet
Europe has been very good at voicing
moral and rhetorical support for the
transition in Tunisia without creating
economic strategies that would help this
country kind of recover economically and
this is very important because the
people in Tunisia have had such high
expectations after the uprising that
this new phase will bring prosperity to
the country and stability etc that they
have started to become rather
disappointed because of the economic
crisis and actually it's very normal for
any country undergoing transition to
have economic problems and so the
Tunisians are looking at Europe and
again feeling a bit abandoned feeling
that they need more support that is not
happening and here I'm talking about
trade I'm talking about investment the
kinds of economic agreements that would
help this country
because if people feel disappointed with
you know their everyday lives after a
period of political change than this
risks them losing hope and democracy
altogether and unfortunately some people
already in Tunisia are beginning to say
well at least during the days of Ben Ali
the ousted dictator you know we we made
a good living and now we're not which is
very unfortunate the third issue I will
raise is that of politics hard politics
and here I'm talking in particular about
Syria
unfortunately Syria is a country that
has reached this sad state that it's in
today largely as a result of the
inattention of the international
community very early on after the Syrian
uprising when the uprising turned into
a conflict but before it became a
full-blown war there still could have
been a diplomatic way after the crisis
but the international community in
general did not seem to have a vision
for how to do this and Europe in
particular became very clear as an actor
that was largely waiting for the United
States to take a lead the EU in
particular became an institution that
seemed to have very little political
function when it came to the
International Relations of the Middle
East people saw that the EU was almost
in impotent not really doing much to
help this crisis
find an end and now more than four years
after the crisis started we are
beginning to see this huge wave of
Syrians reach European Shores some of
them alive many of them dead
unfortunately
until now there have been 3,000 dead
migrants in the Mediterranean 70% of
whom are Syrian and so this state of
affairs is a result of this conflict
grinding on and the reason why people
are now starting to try to reach Europe
and larger numbers than before it's
partly out of despair because the people
who are coming to Europe are not just
coming from Syria itself but also from
Lebanon and Jordan where a lot of
Syrians have been seeking refuge over
the last four years and in these
countries these refugees have no rights
their living conditions are dire they
are not allowed to work and therefore
they feel that they're simply wasting
their lives the young people who are
educated who are living in these
countries can
do by working under the table and menial
jobs while the people with families
don't want their children to be raised
in this environment and become either
members of criminal gangs or perhaps
terrorist groups or dark starvation and
so they feel that even though there's a
risk of death reaching trying to reach
Europe is better than staying where they
were and so here again Europe's
political retreat has directly impacted
the humanitarian situation are in the in
the Arab world as you can see and I'm
here I'm talking about Syria in
particular so unfortunately the
perspective from the region regarding
Europe is largely one of despair
disappointment feeling of abandonment
and here as you can see we're talking
about security we're talking about the
economy and we're talking about politics
thank you I promise you an interesting
exchange because I must say I would take
issue with a couple of points that Lina
has made it's always more interesting I
think for the audience when the speakers
agree on everything there's not much to
debate and I'll just mention briefly
what they are first of all as you'll see
in a few moments the European Union has
devoted many many years and I would say
misguidedly to democracy promotion in
different forms in North Africa and in
the Levant I'll describe that very
briefly and it's not as if the European
Union institutions especially have not
sought to do this there's been a very
active policy on that for more than a
decade and secondly I think the implicit
model behind much that Lina said was the
expectation that outside actors would
come in and would somehow transform the
situation within these countries whereas
in fact I think what the United States
and the Europeans have learned over the
last 10 or 15 years whether in Eastern
Europe whether in Ukraine or or in Syria
or in North Africa is that an
indispensable condition for
transformation of societies is what is
called more and more local
ownership the political forces within
the countries themselves must embrace
the objectives and if they don't then
the effort to impose change even
pro-democracy change from outside I
think is doomed to failure beginning in
2003 2004 after the successful
relatively successful experience with
the hungry with the the Czech Republic
with the estonia with poland and the
various other countries that had
overthrown communism the EU then in 2003
2004 for said to itself but what about
the countries surrounding the European
Union who are not destined to become
members and so the EU developed a policy
for the whole of the southern and
eastern Mediterranean in which basically
it spent a decade negotiating with his
countries still under the ancien régime
before the Arab uprisings getting them
to commit themselves to certain reforms
to sign up for them and in exchange
offering a certain number of incentives
financial incentives but also in the
words of the former Italian Prime
Minister Romano Prodi offering to bring
them closer to the European Union to
offer them everything short of actually
being members a very very ambitious
policy that gave rise to hope around the
Mediterranean that the eerily sought to
embrace its neighbors and to help them
move ahead and to help them to into a
transition process which would bring
about democratic reforms and now this
policy was pursued actively beginning in
2004 with the goal of creating a ring of
well governed states around the European
Union in the words of the Sharma a new
columnist in The Economist magazine
about six months ago he said that
instead of creating a ring of well
governed states we now faced a ring of
of fire and I think the reason for this
lie
partly within the countries concerned
predominantly within the countries
concerned better listed because the
policies that we were pursuing was
misguided and I think misguided for a
number of reasons first of all we did
not really have a legal standing or a
right to propose intrusive reforms in
these countries without offering the
membership without having some basis for
interfering effectively in their
internal affairs as we heard with the
candidates for membership
we offered actually rather far-reaching
financial support we set up a bank
especially to promote infrastructure
projects grant assistance to support
civil society a whole range of projects
but taken together the incentive
provided for these was clearly not
sufficient we also had a complicated
tangled web of initiatives I won't
repeat all the Akron isms to you but
whether the euro-mediterranean
partnership or the Union for the
Mediterranean the partnership for
democracy and shared prosperity any
number of initiatives that created
confusion but I think the most serious
failing and Lina did in fact refer to
this indirectly was the fact that the
member states of the European Union most
of which have long-standing traditional
in many cases post-colonial links with
these countries basically organized
their relations with them on the basis
of traditional foreign policy objectives
promoting trade investment security
access to resources in a number of cases
countries like Algeria and Libya clearly
were very important in terms of
hydrocarbons in other words traditional
foreign policies and during this period
they delegated to the institutions in
Brussels the promotion of democracy
and we therefore pursued this policy
that I've described to you but without
the full support of our member states
there are a number of occasions when
this was evident at the very start of
this policy for example the former
French president chirac
visited Tunisia so just as the EU was
selling a package of reforms to these
countries he visited Ben Ali the former
dictator and said that from his point of
view the most important human rights
were the right to food and to lodging
and that from this perspective Tunisia
was doing pretty well so if you had this
kind of message coming from the French
president how could the chisholm
Tunisian regime or any of the other
regimes take seriously the kind of tough
political conditionality that Brussels
was trying to impose and we've seen this
throughout the process in 2000 and and
and the engagement that we tried during
those years were with the the former
dictators and and so for example
President Mubarak was together with
former French president Sarkozy the
co-president of the Union for the
Mediterranean so there was a real effort
to engage with his Audion regime but
relatively poor results then beginning
in Tunisia in December 2010 where the
Arab uprisings how did this look in
Brussels well in Brussels people said
well it's happening again
this is as if the Berlin Wall had fallen
for a second time we've done this before
we know how to do it this is like
another year of Europe and so the EU
then in fact jumped in with a series of
initiatives that were modelled very very
closely on our policies in Central and
Eastern Europe in fact it was almost a
carbon copy of the kind of very
ambitious agreements that we've
negotiated with
in central needs to Europe that we then
proposed to these countries and the EU
then spent several years providing
financial support providing technical
assistance infrastructure investment and
advice about transition however there
were New Kids on the Block we were not
the only influences in these countries
and we could not or should not have
taken for granted that the predominant
motivation of people in these countries
was to become more like ourselves this
was in fact the case in Central and
Eastern Europe the return to Europe of
VAT Slav hava this is solidarity in
Poland however other countries were
active on the same terrain whether the
Gulf countries that were providing
financial support that far exceeded our
own without the kind of Western
political conditionality to pro
democracy can do that we imposed to give
you an example
EU grant assistance to Egypt over a
five-year period around 800 million
support from the Gulf countries over two
years there are different figures
depends how you count it but of the
order of four billion and without the
kind of strings that we were attaching
to it so there were the Gulf countries
that were active Russia in various not
very constructive ways became involved
the Chinese investing large amounts in
infrastructure buying up ports providing
funds for investment with no political
strings others to the Turks with their
own agenda a candidate for EU membership
but still pursuing goals which some have
described as sort of sunni supremacist
goals which were rather different in
nature from the --use so i think because
the EU and its member states did not
speak with one voice because we wrongly
assumed that there was a transition
process underway very similar to the one
that we had dealt with relatively
successfully in central Eastern Europe
because there were other influences in
these societies including conservative
values there were transnational groups
with sectarian objectives using violent
means that we had no means to address
and then as Lina had said we lacked the
diplomatic tools the unity the capacity
or in my view even the standing to try
and impose from outside either reforms
within the countries or diplomatic
solutions to very complex problems of
the sort that we've seen in Syria so we
are now in a sense reaping the whirlwind
of all of this with the outpouring of
refugees particularly from Syria but I
should point out not only from Syria the
160 thousand or so refugees that have
arrived in Italy this year from Libya
are predominantly from sub-saharan and
Eastern Africa from the Sudan from
Somalia from Eritrea earlier on some
from Mali the refugees entering the EU
through Turkey are predominantly now
from Syria but also from from
Afghanistan and from other countries to
the east with turkey acting as a transit
route into Europe through through Greece
so we now face a refugee crisis on an
unprecedented scale that comes on top of
three other existential crises that the
U is facing they still unresolved euro
crisis that you're going to be
discussing here in the coming days the
russia-ukraine question that has been
pushed on to the backburner willfully on
the part of Russia in the light of the
situation in Syria but still remains a
fundamental problem facing Europe the
risk that one of the --use major Member
States the one that I know best the
United Kingdom might withdraw and the
refugee crisis has created new rifts
between countries that previously work
together like Poland and Germany that
were becoming much closer but now on the
refugees you find themselves in
different
camps mrs. Marko who has been championed
as the real political leader of Europe
in the absence of strong leadership in
many other countries I think is now
being called into question in her own
country
I think she'll survive I don't think
there's any very serious competition
within Germany that's still her very
open and welcoming policy towards the
refugees which in human terms is very
heartwarming and has helped to redress
the image of Germany that there was in
Greece for example during the euro
crisis has been very hard-hearted
nonetheless was her own policy it wasn't
thoroughly coordinated within Germany
itself nor was it coordinated with other
EU member states who now reproach
Germany for offering such a welcome
without putting into place the capacity
for lead to receive the refugees in any
event Europe strongest leader Angela
Merkel is finding herself probably in
the most difficult position she has
since the start of her period in office
as German Chancellor so these issues
that were discussing this evening very
important as they are in their own right
and concerning the countries themselves
and with a huge human cost and cost in
human suffering also feed into the other
principal challenges that the European
Union is facing so I think we're in for
a very hot time in the in the years
ahead
you